[Music]
the pre-pandemic parenting playbook
vast and varied so often dictated by
pressure
and privilege for the lucky there was
classical music
learning to code as they learnt to count
and speak spanish before they could
stand
for many preschool life was bubbling and
busy
this is not my schedule this is not my
husband's schedule this is kid's
schedule
but not for all and not for long
the pandemic hitting pause no matter
your position
if life and learning were unequal before
covet what does it look like now
what's the impact and how long will it
last
[Music]
it's a truth persistent and problematic
how well off you are likely to have an
impact on the performance of your child
it's well known that there's an
attainment gap between affluent children
and their less well-off peers as they
pass through the education system
it's less well known that that
attainment gap exists before children
even start
school over a year ago before the
pandemic hit we set out to ask
why a year later after a pandemic no one
could have predicted
we're returning to ask what the impact
has been and if things have got worse
in 2019 71 of children starting school
were at the expected learning level
for those on free school meals it was 55
but there isn't data yet and what
happened during the pandemic
i've been coming here since she was
about nine weeks
old it is difficult because you
you know i can't afford to go out and
pay for soft play every day and things
like that and
even getting around like the bus still
costs money
so it's you know it's been really
important for both of us
that these centers have been open there
are many thousands of parents like kathy
supported by child centers free for
those who need
plugging some of the gap for those who
can't pay
we've all said we would be lost without
it absolutely
how long has the walk in five minutes
five minutes
before the pandemic kathy would be here
numerous times a week
play group plus classes in cooking and
weaning eliza was ahead for her age
a year on things are different when
lockdown happened
it was gone overnight and
i know that kids are easy to adjust to
things but that must have had some kind
of effect
the fact that all of a sudden your whole
life has completely changed
the center she relied on so much has
become a medical hub
she's only been a handful of times all
year she's sure
it's had an impact she just wanted to
sit down and watch tv
all day she didn't want to play with her
toys she didn't want to do any arts and
crafts or anything she just wanted to
sit down and watch tv
she definitely stopped just kind of
going out there she just wanted to sit
it almost feels like you're not doing
enough
as a parent because
they're not doing what they're supposed
to be doing then or what you want them
to be able to do
it was really hard really hard
nurseries remained open for all children
during the second and third lockdowns
but during the first only the vulnerable
and children of key workers could attend
the harm wrought now coming to light
the early years alliance represents
those working with preschool children
in an exclusive survey of their members
three-quarters
said they'd seen changes in the learning
and development of children who stayed
at home during the first lockdown and
nearly 60
said fewer children are now at the
expected level of learning
at teddy bear corner in warwickshire not
all children returned
for those that did the impact was stark
some of them came back
and had thrived in lockdown but then
other children
it kind of gone the other way their
speech and language had kind of gone
back to where it was before they started
with us
and the children move up to us they
mainly all potty trained
we noticed that they kind of regressed
during lockdown and came back and
were kind of back needed reminding to go
to the toilet
the children who haven't necessarily had
that support from us this
year because of covid they're not
necessarily ready
emotionally and socially to go into
school i don't know if they'll ever get
that time back
and are you worried about some of these
children going forward yes the ones
that are going to school in september if
they're the ones that have got
you know difficulties
we don't have long now to put those
things the provisions in place that we
normally would
but they're most worried about the
already disadvantaged
some have fallen disproportionately
behind
in fact nearly half of early years
practitioners said the gap between the
worst off children and their peers
has widened since the start of the
pandemic that is
brilliant what's up guys sue's run this
nursery for 25 years
there's a mix of children here from a
wide range of homes
leveling the playing field has always
been paramount but it's never been
harder
i think lockdown did have a profound
effect on them
the equalities have always been there
but i think it's going to
to get worse to get worse to the
detriment of all the children we look
after
this generation could well be a
partially lost generation from some
things
and in all your 25 years of working in
the sector have you ever
seen something that would have such an
impact on children this one
no the difference in outcomes is likely
to be down to a complex mix of factors
cramped living conditions perhaps or
parents working multiple jobs that can't
be done from home
experts in this field are keen to
emphasize that all families are
different and that the pandemic has
taken a deep toll
on all sorts of different people for all
sorts of different reasons
but many fear the really detrimental
impacts will last longest
in the most vulnerable that children
will carry them through their time at
school
entrenching already deep social and
educational inequalities
you made it elsie may started attending
this nursery during the first lockdown
when her family qualified for extra
support
it was probably
the lowest point i've ever been as a
parent nothing was as hard as
as the the first lock down
philomena's a single parent and her
elder son has special needs
look right forward she says the extra
nursery time for elsie may literally
kept the family together
but that time has still taken its toll
well she's definitely regressed
um milestones that she was hit in
um toilet in things like that of you
know
we've she's massively regressed in them
to the point where you know i've had to
have the healthiest involved now you
worry as well that the impact of this
will stay with her with her forever yeah
i truly believe it will she used to be
such a sparky little thing
i do think for elsie may it's
changed her personality it's changed her
little way of thinking
but others are more isolated this is
talitha and her twins thomas
and teguin hello morning
how are you i'm fine thank you when we
met them last year life was just
settling down
they'd been homeless for a few months
early in the twins lives
a baby bank delivery another huge help
it's a bit overwhelming in there because
i didn't expect all this stuff
when you're like a single mum you don't
want anyone to think you can't cook you
don't want people to think you can
do the things that you need to do
there's a bit of you that feels like you
can't do it
but you can do it because it takes a lot
to ask for help
it takes more to ask for help than it
does to sit and struggle on your own
money was tight but talitha was positive
take her in the red
but a year later she didn't feel up to
catching up with us on camera
like so many she's found the pandemic
very difficult and very isolating
she was happy for us to report that the
twins are well but the family
have barely been out for a year as clear
as sign as any of covid's cruel
but quiet impacts
my
[Music]
there are many hidden tolls to this
pandemic
the worst may not be realized for years
taken
on those too young to remember
[Music]